el primer vuelo desde tel aviv a
marruecos llegó a tierra así se inicia
una simbólica conexión aérea resultado
de la normalización de relaciones entre
marruecos e israel intermediada por eeuu
a bordo de este vuelo comercial directo
entre ambas naciones viajaron el yerno y
consejero de trump jared kushner y el
embajador en israel
[Música]
israel inicia su normalización con un
sexto país árabe y el cuarto en los
últimos cuatro meses cada acuerdo de paz
se mantiene solo cada uno debe ser
celebrado y juntos van a ser reconocidos
como el cambio en medio oriente
en la víspera de la visita
jared kushner se reunió con el primer
ministro israelí benjamín netanyahu
quien celebró los nuevos lazos y elogió
al rey marroquí y mayor favor de la
calidad saludos y por parte de toda la
gente israel por la valiente e
importante decisión histórica que ha
tomado surgen de disney el vuelo desde
telaviv hasta rabat tomó alrededor de 6
horas con un desvío para evitar volar
sobre ar
el ya que no ha normalizado sus
relaciones con israel tras el exitoso
aterrizaje los oficiales de ambos países
firmarán una serie de acuerdos
marruecos es el hogar de la mayor
comunidad judía del norte de áfrica
mientras que miles de israelíes son
descendientes marroquíes ambos países
reabrirán sus sedes diplomáticas después
de que marruecos cerrará su oficina en
tel aviv en el 2000 con el inicio del
segundo levantamiento palestino el rey
mohamed sexo ha dicho que marruecos
seguirá apoyando la causa palestina no
obstante los palestinos han condenado la
normalización como han hecho con los
pactos recientes de israel con otros
países árabes acusando a los estados de
entorpecer el proceso de paz